time now for morning rounds our look at
the medical news of the week this
morning a condition that is so common
you actually may not think of it as a
mental health problem we're talking
about loneliness previously published
research suggests there could be a link
between being lonely and your overall
health
a new survey released by the health
services company Cigna tried to gauge
the extent of loneliness in America a
little over 20,000 adults were surveyed
using the UCLA lonely in a scale a
questionnaire designed to evaluate the
level of loneliness and our social
isolation that someone might feel for
more we are joined by dr. Gail Saltz she
is a psychiatrist and the author of the
book the power of different the link
between disorder and genius welcome back
doctors thank you for having me
so let's talk about this when you look
at some of the results that Cigna
published did anything surprise you as a
mental health professional
no probably to the general public yes
because really the numbers are quite
high many many of us are at least
sometimes there feeling quite lonely and
many people actually are always feeling
quite lonely which is really important
it has physical health ramifications
mental health ramifications and you
could say that this rises to the level
of true public health concern it was
there sort of the generational
difference like an age difference and
more so in one category that's what
might surprise people the most I'm not
surprised but in the 18 to 22 year old
category that was actually those people
scored the highest in terms of lonely's
we tend to think of lonely as a sort of
an older person's problem but actually
the scores were highest for the youngest
group 18 to 22 and remained high and
dropped very slowly until the oldest
group and you would be like well is
there any indication as to why well I I
think that there is actually the study
didn't look at that specifically but if
you think about it right people are
marrying later than ever
marriage is actually and partnership is
a big antidote to loneliness we human
beings evolutionarily are social
creatures we need to bond it was a
method of survival so when you don't
have someone or people that you're
bonded to right that creates real
problems so later marriage less marriage
people moving
farther apart from each other than ever
before I think about our older
generations families stayed together now
people spread out all over and a lot of
feeling that you don't agree with other
people we're very divided and that
creates a sense of lack of intimacy lack
of being included which leads loneliness
you know the later marriage thing I know
my mom is watching she's going to be
calling because there are some real
physical health issues that are linked
to this phenomena that is correct and as
I mentioned earlier because
evolutionarily were meant to bond when
we don't have people that were bonded to
or feel close with it creates a sense of
danger for us because it was long ago
dangerous and that makes us release the
cortisol the the hormone cortisol which
is the stress hormone which causes
cardiovascular problems hardening of
arteries decrease in immunity more
likely to get infections that decrease
in immunity also leads to higher rates
of cancer so there are lots of actual
physical health problems that can occur
as a result of prolonged feelings of
loneliness in addition to that
depression is a big result of loneliness
and depression is actually the number
one source of disability in this country
it's a very common illness and
loneliness can be a big precursor I
would have thought that social media
impacted this as well but it didn't have
as big of an impact as I would think so
actually it's a little misleading it
says it doesn't have an impact but
really what we're talking about is a
bimodal group so the group that uses
social media to add to their in person
contacts and keep the relationship
better so to speak that group it did not
impact not surprisingly but there are
many people who don't have in-person
contacts who are only on social media
sort of looking looking at what other
people doing looking at how other people
are not alone or it seems like other
point where not resent what you want and
that group it really does enhance those
feelings of loneliness we know that that
social media leads to more depression in
morning's ID and that may be another
factor for the young group is their
there was a New York Times report that
came out a few weeks ago that suggested
that boys are more risk for factors that
include
including an increased alienation at
this study look at that by gender it did
not well actually not take that back it
did in a very broad way and found that
both males and females really do suffer
from this now they may handle it
different and that may be something that
the other study looked at so men tend to
get more angry when they're isolated etc
and women more crying in the shower as
we were speaking about so there may be
differences in reaction but it does
affect both men and women and I would
say you know we have to consider this as
a public health issue and what can we do
there are things we can do to encourage
people to have more in-person contacts
like you know your mother will do later
open a conversation that's right and get
our people to join you and there's not
too much that's not too much dr. Gail
Saltz we're out of time for this
conversation but thank you my pleasure